[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quarterback
from the uh notre dame fighting army she
and book joining us on the program the
irish now
second in the country at 10-0 defeating
syracuse over the weekend good morning
ian how are you i'm doing great how are
you i'm doing okay
um did you have an nfl team you rooted
for growing up
i did yeah as the 49ers grew up a fan
and
still am a fan so watch every game on
sunday and
um you know you start to look at these
teams
as you you're going to be draft eligible
here coming up here in a in a couple of
weeks
what have you been told as far as your
your pro
prospects or what the scouts might think
about your talents
a lot of people right now just saying
focus on the season and uh
you know let that take care of itself
but it's been a dreamline to play in the
nfl and
that's that's what i want to do so um
you know i'm ready for that and
i'll be willing to go wherever whenever
it's just a dream of mine and
i don't care where it'll be so who are
you compared to who's playing in the nfl
a lot of people i mean this is big
praise because
you know russell wilson's probably my
favorite but a lot of people say
you know russell wilson uh maybe baker
mayfield
a couple of the shorter guys which is
cool i love watching them all on sunday
and
uh it's just fun to see how the league
with quarterbacks has changed a little
bit it's definitely motivating
are you a runner or a scrambler
uh that's a good question i i'd probably
scrambler uh when it breaks down you
know i think
i can make some plays with my feet and
keep the play alive and
that's just kind of how i've been
playing the game since you know i
started in third grade
this is what i would say just a little
bit of advice whenever you talk to
a scout or a coach general manager
anybody
just say i'm here to help you win
that's it that's that's all you do
because that's what you do in college
that's all russell wilson did when he
was in college i'm just here to help you
win because they're going to go well
you're six feet are you a legitimate six
feet
i'm legitimate six feet yep okay because
they're gonna go six feet
um okay how's your arm strength
uh does he run uh does he have happy
feet does he run too soon like all of
these things are they're going to pick
you apart
oh yeah and you've got to be really
confident in yourself
to just say through all of it i don't
care what
you break me down i win that's what i'm
here to do i'm here to win
all right yes sir okay but let's try it
here
all right okay so if i say man i'm
looking at the tape here
um i don't know do you pull it down and
run too much here
uh how's the arm strength there um
i don't know uh ian help me out trying
to understand your talents here
yeah i'm just i just play to win i'm
here to win i'm here to
here to move the team you know move the
chains and on offense i'm here to win
all right there you go just say it over
and over and over don't get defensive
when they start to pick you apart
because i i've been with some of the
best who've ever played it and they all
got picked apart
as well uh who who gets your heisman
vote
if you had one um
uh i don't know i think kyle trask is
really good been watching him
um you know watched his game last week
and i think he's doing really well and
he's fun to watch and
he's really elevated his game right now
okay
i i don't understand why you don't get
any credit here
and i and i and i say that um having you
on but i've said that before you came on
i don't i mean you put up really good
numbers and you win
but you're not put in the conversation
of great quarter i'm talking
college quarterbacks we tend to lump
quarterbacks in what they're going to be
like when they get to the nfl
i'm just talking about what you do in
college and that's what i'm surprised at
i think you should be
certainly in the conversation for a
heisman finalist i don't know if you're
going to get there but
you win and you're the second you're
ranked second in the country so help me
understand
what you hear as to why you're not
lumped in with any of these other
quarterbacks right now
you know i'm not you know i'm not 100
sure there's probably a lot of reasons
out there but you know one of them could
be just because
we're at notre dame uh you either love
us or you hate us
it's one of the others so you know a lot
of people
you know talked about you know a
conference you know they can't win if
they were to join a conference or
just a lot of things like that and we
were able to join a conference this year
and
you know go undefeated in it so um did
you hate notre dame growing up
no i didn't oh come on
i grew up you know really watching the
pac-12 on the west coast and
really fortunate to get out here i'm
really glad i did it's been an
unbelievable experience but
i didn't hate notre dame like a lot of
people do if it wasn't notre dame where
were you going
i was committed to washington state
that's where i was going to go i was
going to join the air raid and
play in the pac-12 and i ended up making
the switch
well i think you made a pretty good
switch there when's the last time uh
coach kelly yelled at you
uh during the game uh during the game we
had a
a fumble so and uh that's on the
quarterback always saw and uh
i definitely heard from him a little bit
on the sideline but you know he's been
really good on the sideline just this
whole entire year so
he came back and and gave me some
support we were able to finish the deal
do you have a dresser behind you what's
in those drawers what's in those drawers
behind you
i don't know that's a good question uh
can you get up and just open it up and
just let me know if there's anything
like it that's just there's some file
cabinets
got some secret stuff in there some
notre dame stuff some uh some stuff that
you'll use against clemson in the ac
aacc title yeah
exactly two weeks to prepare it's all in
there how much did it bother you with
trevor lawrence not playing you guys
beat clemson and then you hear
well but trevor lawrence didn't play
right um
i kind of ignored it because i kept
saying well trevor lawrence doesn't play
defense
so it was the same for us and my job is
to win
right that's what we said my job is to
win is the quarterback and
whoever they were gonna the 11 guys they
were going to put out there on defense
is what we were going to go against and
um i think it'll be good that he's back
and uh
you know hopefully we can get those
people to be quiet because that's what
i've heard a lot just like you have
how much of an advantage is it to have
two weeks to prepare for clemson
yeah a lot i mean it's good just to
finish the regular season have two weeks
now just to rest up
you know mentally and physically and uh
just to play a team twice is always hard
so it's going to be
fun to get back to the drawing boards
i'm really excited about it
you already have your degree yes sir and
what
business marketing are you going to get
a master's
i'm not i'm currently a non-degree
seeking fifth year
so that means you you don't do anything
what does that mean i was a non-degree
seeking like sophomore
so basically i have to take one i had to
take one grad class and then two classes
whatever i wanted i ended up taking
three irish studies classes
really enjoyed it because i was i was
going to go to ireland and then covet
hit
we were going to play in dublin but i
figured might as well you know learn
about some of the
the culture so i took three irish
studies classes this year it was fun
are you studying guinness
no no of course not have you seen the
movie
witness i have not i have not
have you see you know nothing about this
harrison ford movie
where his name is john book no i do not
i need to watch it then yes you're gonna
love it by the way
okay okay but but watch film on clemson
i don't want people thinking oh he's not
watching clemson he's watching a movie
called witness
because the character is is john book
and it's harrison ford
i gotta watch it i'll find time i'll
find time to watch it okay all right
what's your nickname they don't call you
like bookie do they or
no so i mean there's a lot you can do
with my last name
um but i don't think i've ever had a
nickname ian's short enough and it's
just kind of been ian and that's the way
the way it's gone well i had to go to
the ibook once
like an ipad you know how that goes but
that's about it
ibook yeah um
i like the ian we'll just stay with that
yeah well congrats on the season so far
the uh acc title game against clemson is
uh
december 19th what do you do better than
trevor lawrence
um when there well
wait a minute his winning percentage
pretty good at that he's pretty good
he's he's a trick question he's 33-1
you're 30-3 he's got me then he's got me
that's the right answer there no do you
do something where you go
look you're a competitor yeah i think
like what we talked about earlier being
able to scramble and keep my eyes up and
keep the play
alive he can do that too but i've been
doing that for a long time i think
that's one thing that
can help us win like you said help us
move the chains so
well good luck hey great to talk to you
congrats on the season and
were you more emotional your first day
on campus or your last game
uh probably the last game yeah had my
family and uh
senior day and just the fact that it was
gonna be my last time playing in that
unbelievable stadium
tonight i'll remember forever and i was
definitely a little bit emotional and
had the
you know my family with me and that's
who i wanted to be with and i didn't
want to leave the field so i was out
there for a long time
you cry uh no my mom was crying though
it was pretty sad
hmm trevor lawrence would have cried
he might have i don't know it was sad
that was bittersweet
bittersweet no that's a
lot of great memories in that place uh
ian thank you we appreciate your time
and uh good luck against uh clemson
thank you very much thanks for having me
that's uh ian book and he'll watch the
movie witness and then he'll understand
when
somebody yells out
and see